welcome to Microsoft security risk
detection today we're going to talk
about how Microsoft security risk
detection uses Microsoft technology to
find million dollar bugs with the same
technology we use at Microsoft by
creating scalable labs in the cloud
cross-platform support previously
Microsoft security restrictions focused
on Windows and Linux but today we're
going to talk about web applications
this is the a wasp juice shop Oh wasp is
a nonprofit dedicated to teaching the
world about security and web
applications and the OWASP juice shop is
the most vulnerable juice shop on the
Internet
this is an application you can go look
at the source code on github where
terrible terrible things like cross-site
scripting attacks and sequel injection
have been planted in order to help you
understand what's right and what's wrong
about web applications today we're going
to walk through the newest feature in
Microsoft security risk detection web
scanning if you go to Microsoft security
risk detection comm there's a link
called web scans today you can see we've
created something called juice shop
which is a configuration in Microsoft
security risk detection for scanning a
configuration is a set of information
that Microsoft security risk detection
needs in order to reach out to your
website and scan it for critical issues
like cross-site scripting or sequel
injection let me show you first what the
results look like and then I'll show you
how to hit your own scan of your own
website so to look at the results I can
see they're two different scans I'm
going to click on this one the scan
results in Microsoft security risk
detection consists in multiple parts the
first part is a site map the site map
shows you all of the different pieces of
the website that were visited by
Microsoft security risk detection during
the scan and I can actually click on
these different pieces in order to
understand more about the structure of
the site so here I can say oh there's
these different pieces
I can explore explore more of these
there's these different products and I
can even expand all of it in order to
get a complete view of the entire
website so I can drill down into each of
these but I can also just get a sense at
a glance it's like did I get a really
great coverage of my site or not and if
I didn't maybe I can change the
configuration or tweak Microsoft
security risk detection in order to get
better coverage and our team is standing
by to help you understand how to do that
if you don't get the coverage that
you're looking for but then I can take a
look at you know what is a summary I can
see all of these different issues that
have been found the unique URLs but what
if I want to know more about one of
these issues well let me take a look at
the by severity view the by severity
shows me each of the issues have been
found ranked by a high to low severity
so high severity those are the things I
really want to pay attention to
I can click all the way down to get the
specific URL where the issue was found
and it tells me it's a blind sequel this
is the error ID so this is a specific
unique ID which you know you can use for
tagging or monitoring or metrics in your
organization I can say it's very high
severity it's a blind sequel and I can
get the detail and I can see that nine
different variants of the attack were
found during the Microsoft security risk
detection well what is a blind sequel
attack I'm going to click on the more
information to learn more about it so
the more information tells me that this
parameter is probably vulnerable to
sequel injection it's considered blind
because I inferred the vulnerability it
wasn't directly observed but it was
inferred because of specific attack
techniques that capture knowledge that
we have about what is a web
vulnerability and I can see for each of
these attacks this is a request that was
seen and this is the response so now I
can use this I can run this in curl and
it can run against the website and say
exactly what happened and say oh
this is something that is definitely
reproducible it's definitely an issue
and I need to go ahead and make sure I
fix it
so that's a whirlwind tour of the
results that you get and you can see
there's many other high results here but
then what happens if I want to create a
new scan well way we think about it is
there's these things called
configurations so there's juice shop is
one configuration webgoat is another
common application used for training
that has terrible things planned in it
if you want to schedule another scan all
you got to do is push the request web
Scan button which I just did here and
that will schedule a new scan for you to
get created to go after your website I
can see the green checkmark there which
means that Microsoft security risk
detection is going to go off and scan my
website now this is of course for the
juice shop configuration now let me just
quickly walk through what configuration
is and then you can create a new
configuration just by pressing new
configuration button so I'm going to
look at the details of the juice shop
configuration so first of all I have a
name this is something I can use to keep
track of all the different websites I'm
testing and then I want to give it a
route URL and say I want to allow
crawling and I can decide whether or not
I want to allow crawling of child domain
so this is the specific route URL we are
hosting our own copy of the juice shop
code
you can host your copy of juice shop or
you can point this to whatever URL your
application is hosted in the traffic
which is used to do the scanning comes
from the Microsoft security risk
detection servers which are hosted in
Azure those servers have static IP
addresses which we will share with you
so you can inform your IT department to
make sure that they know that you're not
under attack that this is something that
you actually want the an attack
configuration allows you to pick which
modules to test with there are 90
different modules in Microsoft Security
Essentials you want to be enabled for
your application maybe you want to try
everything and just see everything that
could possibly happen or maybe you want
a faster smaller scoped scan which only
looks at things like sequin jacket sicko
injection this particular website
doesn't require any authentication but
you'll see in a second that we can add
form based authentication or other
methods of authentication to make sure
that you can log into your site schedule
we will soon have the ability for the
scheduled scans today you trigger them
manually and then we have advanced
settings such as is there a proxy what's
the maximum burling's to crawl the
connection timeout and so on and so
forth and you can change the header name
and everything in order to make it
trailered it to your application so if I
all I have to do in order to get the
juice shop running is just have a new
configuration I can say I want to add
different kinds of authentication you
can see here here's the list so if you
use this in order to help the crawler
login to your website in order to get
additional coverage if there's a form of
a vacation you want but you don't see
here email fuzzing at Microsoft comm to
ask for it to be added and our team can
help you make workarounds in the near
term to get better coverage in your
website and you can even give us a set
of selenium scripts to run a set of
traffic recordings or swagger documents
that give the crawler additional
information about your website in order
to help you find more stuff faster so
this is something that you can use in
order to find serious issues in your
websites and this is juice shop as just
an example of Microsoft security
rejection giving you coverage caused
Windows applications Linux applications
and web applications for more
information on this and other features
go to Microsoft comm /ms Rd that's
Microsoft comm / ms Rd where you can
find additional information around how
Microsoft's curious detection helps you
with applications across your entire
estate thank you